ma con salve a tutti i ragazzi minuti
questo nuovo video sono bravi james oggi
siamo su allora prima cosa i fazzoletti
cazzo usa li siamo su un altro è partito
così siamo su ball boy che sarebbe
questa
questo è bellissimo bambino che è uscito
da pochissimo su steam la versione
completa praticamente tra
vedremo adesso partiamo perché è una
storia è una storia non faceva una
storia da un secolo perché sembra una
per al sole alla luna e quella è la luna
non sembra una lampadina anche la chiesa
e la lampadina no vabbè tutta una
lampadina bug in inglese significa
lampadina a quella il nonno che bello sì
comunque ti spieghi meglio del mio prof
di fisica ma è tutta lampadina ragazzi
una finestra è addormentato così cosa
che cazzo hai detto ma posso già
muovermi fantastico no io già lo amo
allora devo andare a letto e non sia
addormentato dio mio perfetto dentiera e
televisione angelo spegnere la tv aver
giusto giusto non si spreca niente come
questo non è un tv canale o dio the ring
poi cosentino perché chi bravi
bravissimi bellissimo spegnerlo starò
papale tutto il video reja pollice in su
per genialata se facesse stuprando il
tasto zio dove vi sono spegnere la
televisione non era difficile e che ne
so quindi ragazzi abbiamo spento il
televisore manca la dentiera perché c'è
fra bieber non senti devo prenderti la
dentiera
ma sei serio e o supposto prato al mouse
provano fatto bra che me ne faccio ma
che schifo perché alla la dentiera nel
pesce dentro la bocca ma se io non ho
parole per questa seduta mettere in
bocca buona notte
che bello cosa cazzo è quella roba a
delle ali no delle gambe anno sono ali
auguro di non aver acchiappamosche in
casa o acchiappa cani brutti con le ali
qualsiasi cosa sia che sarà ma comunque
per ora best inizio
è vero scusate c'è una falla nera che si
sta avvicinando a casa mia entrate in
casa una palla nera che sta facendo
oddio no no non attento no non c'è un
cessata na in questo torneo a bada il
perfetto come ci volete la dentiera zio
e non volevo non volevo dire e ti
capisco quando mi svegliavo per andare a
scuola era la stessa cosa ho sentito dei
rumori in salotto
devo andare in salotto perché c'è una
perché gira questo è peggio che
preferivo light cui non è una pena mosca
perché c'è la stanza piena di insetti
che sono più grossi di tecnica ma
facciamo regno così a dare fuoco a tutta
la casa propria a vuole mangiare sto
stronzo
la mossa non la posso prendere troppo in
alto sotto al letto giustamente mi devi
spiegare da quant'è che un pubblicista
stanza su cos'è sta roba lì devo una
scopa perché si è infilato una scopa nel
culo e una scopa con la quale forse
posso raggiungere l'insetto ecco
perfetto cioè abbiamo ragazzi abbiamo il
primo importante che riusciamo il
cassetto è un po d'ordine nella tua vita
potresti anche farlo alla madonna che
sono in gradi attivisti insetti a devo
farlo arrivare alla foca piton fanno
arrivare alla fine perfetto dovrebbe
dovresti esserci zio non lo so è
perfetto perfetto ok lo pigliano
perfetto grande ce l'abbiamo ragazzi le
banche a 1
ma ecco bilancio il pupazzo in faccia
non devi strozzati colpo pazzo di
rilanciarle qualcosa ma l'inizio addio
[Musica]
questo fatto ok bella va bene non so
come ho fatto a spider man show alle
cose allora questo è lombrico
accompagnano con un buon san crispino e
vedi che l ultimo ma non meno importante
il dolce che offre la casa intrinseco
tra la mosca il tiramisù e si chiama
mosca misurava zio e la madonna a morire
atrocemente a new york nonna non sei tu
dio santo c'è il mio nonno che ancora in
preda a quella merda di coso nero perché
tu sei malvagio io non sapevo se è stata
la cosa più inutile di tutta la stanza
mi sembrava strano ragazzini importante
che troviamo al nonno poi non so che
nonna esatto il problema è che c'è un
coso lì a terra è venuto a trovarmi a
casa rocco siffredi non protestano va
seriamente ragazzi ma mi fa male solo
tocco
mi fa male se lo so cosa diavolo 6
sì però stai calma cosa che mi spunta
dal pavimento bene spesso franco che
trovo come impossibile ok che sono la
lampadina ma posso ma veramente io posso
attaccarmi ai lampadari va bene sono
l'uomo lampadario sono posso andar di
gioco perfetto regalo bellissimo il
problema è che è morto un uccello di
flop i bears è morto luce quindi niente
ho preso un pezzo di vetro ragazzi sono
ancora deciditi dove vuoi andare io sto
maniaco continua a perseguitarmi non da
sinistra e basta fatti i cazzi tuoi dove
posso andare di qua
ancora niente lega non c'è verso cos'è
sono diventato un cavaliere ragazzi
braidesi la porta la mia volta ho capito
forse no sì ho capito grande una
batteria a zio nel senso che italico
club perfetto gran botta ragazzi questa
cosa si mangia posso prenderla e
portarla a tavola
no che faccia schifo perché fa male
fotte sei anni basta che andiamo avanti
e stata un'esperienza bellissima
grazie mille sono un uomo migliore sto
amando questo gioco è bellissimo non ha
senso
no no no no no no no bastardi non può
essere vero
e morto è morto sul serio è morto alla
dentiera la dentiera senza la dentiera
non si sveglia ci sono non ti
preoccupare ci siamo dove sta andando
2 buy vabbè che succede oddio nonno se
gli ha posto
no no
no no io
e vabbè è sparito al nonno ma la
dentiera equa e andato sul soffitto che
è successo al soffitto a posso staccarmi
e lanciarmi sul soffitto e tanto ormai
siamo alla madonna ed andare su posso
arrampicarmi su che belli sforzi che fai
oddio se non in paradiso
sono morto e se successo giorno che la
faccia che ci sarà bambino stava
scherzando è bellissimo quando ridere
non so perché ancora un cielo di floppy
bird sta ricordando che infatti sembrava
strano non è possibile c'è ancora no eh
beh c'è ancora nonno che bello che mio
nonno chiedendo dov'è finito il cane
ragazzi gara gli ho visto solo
all'inizio l'ho visto che placa la palla
e lancia la palla dai agosta palla vai
così al volo non vedi scopi ad una
[ __ ] noemi a quella palla grazie non
vi serve proprio a vuole un nuovo volo
trovano a equa l'uomo che mi faccio
tutto nel culo lo caga toyo zio sto
nuovo lo vuoi te lo infilo nell'albero
grande zio non era esattamente quello
che intendevo veloci a lanciarli l'uomo
prima che torni la pre dai dai che fa
centro ma è tornata un ciclo
se ciò fa che bello che hai quando ride
86 che basta che c'è la palla
giochiamo amico mio c'è una mira che fa
veramente eh vabbè ce l'hai davanti ma
sei scemo ma ecco questo serve il cesso
ma era più semplice di quanto pensassi
che io suo sì a tirar le palle sia ad
avere tempismo sono una merda su
perfetto ma non te la lancio più sei
scemo vabbè telara prova da
sinistra è un caso perso cosa righi se
in deficiente guaribile anche caner il
cache bella scena dal polpettone il
polpettone no
che cosa vi chiariti perché ridono
perché è la scena più trash che io abbia
mai visto nella storia dei videogame
questo ci insegna che l'importante non è
saper lanciare la palla l'importante è
far volare il polpettone è stato
stupendo assenterà ok al piano di sopra
non sei qui vecchio ragazzi che sono che
l'episodio io ve lo dico
era da un bel po che non trova un gioco
e con una trama senza dire niente perché
non dicono niente e bellissima veramente
film sto divertendo un sacco quindi
aspetta nei prossimi episodi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto
quindi ragazzi se il video mi è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato un commento è un
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook con
il video schizzate sera si rischia
ragazzi